[Music]
[Applause]
we're here
Ben Freedom let's go baby Justice to
defend the American values American
democracy
and first and foreign
this is a Christian Nation and I'll be
dead before that changes ladies and
gentlemen we are all domestic terrorists
you're looking tiny today Hassan did you
shrink am I look you asked specifically
before we started to make himself look
larger on camera
no I didn't yes you did
well only only to compensate for the
real head size comparison leak that
happened earlier on the Twitter page I
did ask that but but Ian undid it this
is my natural size now I'm getting up
oh there it is listen I I don't
appreciate that you have a hotkey back
dude you've lost so much weight that
that is your natural size now it's kind
of crazy thank you you are you're you're
in your Ethan era for sure 100 my hot
girl era yeah so Hassan who uh has
graciously sat here and watched me
promote Teddy fresh every week has his
own uh
thing going on here that's right for the
first time in in like months
uh I am doing something that I am
obligated to do by uh my merchandising
apparel company they're making you do
this I mean they they they ask very uh
kindly they're like they're paying for
it then right
uh yes and yes yeah they are they are
they are they are well this is also a
cool thing no no it's not even it's not
even for this part is not this part is
irrelevant the ideology hoodies are back
in stock
um that's the I think that's the old one
I don't think it's the new one can I buy
this um pan
you cannot buy the pan but it's uh this
is your brain on ideology I'm sorry I
failed on that but Sunday I'm gonna be
doing a pop-up shop because uh my friend
uh Miggy at reconstruct
on Melrose you guys have probably seen
it well maybe not you guys but everybody
in my community knows uh he takes old
gear old clothes and and engages in cut
and so like handmade cutting so uh
reconstructed garments it's called
upcycling yeah so he uh we gave him a
bunch of the John Brown collection and
he made Patchwork cutting so uh one of
one uh oh that's fun yeah one of one
like uh like a ideology collab with
reconstruct so those are limited and you
can only get
I guess you could only get them if uh I
forget what it is I think 250 if you've
spent on the website already you have a
chance to win one oh you're just they're
they're giveaways yeah they're giveaways
and same at the pop-up shop as well
so this was so anyway uh well did you
where do people find the address what's
the where's the pop-up the if you go to
audiology.shop yeah it's on there it
says Americorps pop-up if you go to the
main page three oh three three oh
that's uh oh yeah that's some of it
where's the where's the address
here click on the right
up there it is Americorps pop-up shop
oh and if you click on there you can uh
sign up
I gotta be there right now for the
address
do you want anyone to come to this
I think people will come to it how do
they get the address I think they get a
general free general admission ticket by
signing up with their emails aol.com
is that I've been using that email for a
decade bro oh that's like an actual
email you have access to I've been using
it a fake email for a decade oh
wish I had it well that's exciting I
hope that it goes great for you and I'm
sure it will
that's fun
embargo is great I hope I I don't get uh
assassinated I can't believe you Ethan
might pop in actually you're the one who
said it first I wouldn't say it on
camera okay well we'll be all right now
that you're using a gun to Rob this Bank
where'd you guys get that from oh no I'm
going to jail dawg what the hell I said
now this is a perfect opportunity for
someone to know your exact time and
location yeah I didn't say anything
about violence
okay well there will be armed guards
there right yeah yeah we have Auto will
there be explosive devices yeah yeah
yeah I took I took some of the some of
the landmines you had
uh specifically the child ones uh that
you have outside of the 20 trillion
dollar compound yeah and I I uh I'm
gonna bring him over there good so we're
good all right so what do we got on the
DACA today Hawaii's on fire
horrific
although it was apparently Chinese space
laser beams so that's kind of close the
oh dude close the uh you know the case
on that the conspiracies are out of
control but I believe all of them so uh
you know it was actually so
horrific and tragic uh 110 people are
dead I think there's still like 900
missing last I saw
and this whole town was just wiped off
the Earth
and I did not know
that you could have
that devastating of a forest fire in a
goddamn tropical island
but apparently
they've been going through like a super
bad drought in Hawaii there's a there's
a bunch of different reasons for it so
number one
uh Lahaina is the original capital of
the Hawaiian Kingdom and uh it used to
be
you know very well irrigated however due
to the sugar plantations and uh the the
pineapple plantations they basically as
far as I understand moved water away
from that region
which made the grass and which made the
region and the vegetation in general
much more dry
and much more susceptible to Wildfire so
that was number one that's like the
historic reason as to why Lahaina is not
also seen as like uh you know a great
valuable real estate in Hawaii
um
so and that in the beaches or lack
thereof then on top of that they also
brought into the island
uh non-native vegetation which uh
is is not as moist as the native
vegetation on the island like different
kinds of grass
which uh was way more susceptible to
drying and then you have these massive
hurricanes happening uh you know off the
coastline that is carrying uh that has
like 80 mile winds uh you have these
power lines fall
uh because they did not Harden their
infrastructure for the extreme weather
conditions that are now infinitely more
likely and boom you have a Tinder Box
basically ready to erupt
that's sad man that's crazy last place I
expected a devastating forest fire of
course again you know global climate
change is causing weather to be insane
and uh Hawaii's on fire now
uh but like I was saying
the good news is that climate change is
actually a hoax it's a Chinese
conspiracy there's nothing to worry
about because as Tim Poole said
uh it's a space we are not Chinese space
laser in fact or at least it's not a
Jewish space yeah no he he addresses
that he's like you know he addresses
that in the video this is great
let's see
but you can call it whatever you want
but my attitude is you look we are not
we are not on good terms with China
right now I mean we can we can pretend
oh no the trade foreign
that's actually from from what I
understand how horrible and now I mean
they're like our biggest trading partner
by far well he already addressed that by
saying ah trade who gives a
whatever so you're owned on that one oh
you think you think it's important to
have uh a decent trade relationship with
our largest trading partner
um we're all like completely Reliant
just multiple billions of dollars of uh
Commodities being moved back and forth
that's that's valuable to you friendship
where I come from valuable to you Ethan
well let's see let's see let's see
Taiwan they're building up their
military there's a chance for escalation
a chance for conflict they want the
South China Sea and then they've got
ships with Russia coming near the
Illusions coming near U.S territory
going near Hawaii and then they're
pulling off something like this
so look wait what how hard is it to
start a fire it's ridiculously easy to
start a fire well that's part of the
problem dummy if it's that easy to burn
down an entire Island the
problem isn't the laser the problem is
the weather the conditions that
created also the laser is not real okay
but even if it was real yeah like why do
you need a laser go go send like Chinese
Recon then just make a match
yeah I mean we don't even need lasers in
this situation according to Tim
yeah and they can fire lasers okay
it's a little challenging to get the
fire to spread but there were hurricane
level it said it was like hurricane
level winds or there's I don't I don't I
don't have a high winds if they can
start 50 fires what all at once with a
sequence of satellites doing it's not
one it's not one laser it's 50 lasers
then getting that makes sense dude he's
he's like a 14 year old he has the brain
of a child he's like no you don't
understand it's not one laser it's 50
lasers it's like oh okay dude thanks why
don't they do that to Mainland
California then like they could I get
there too you know they didn't
Hassan
you know why he didn't I said how do you
know that they didn't right yeah well so
one of my theories on terrorism and I
this goes out to Al Qaeda whatever Isis
whoever's listening or the Chinese yeah
you could destroy California by just
getting agents in here and just starting
fires all along the coast
I was like why aren't they doing it you
know what I mean because it's like it's
not worth it it's incredibly difficult
to pull off you think so I think I think
like well I mean 9 11 right
that was pretty difficult to pull off
and they sure did it
no you're the Microsoft Microsoft flight
simulator and uh some CIA assets that uh
learned how to learn how to fly a plane
pretty easily but would it be that hard
though like honestly if you I mean if
they have the fire thing they got the
cells apparently they got cells all over
the place who says they shouldn't have
cells in a beautiful Sequoia uh National
Park that would be so sad
I would make a fantastic Isis uh agent
all right if I if I if I was
ideologically matched
[Music]
oh my God
this guy well I asked you you said no I
know but you okay
I guess that's what it's foreign
[Applause]
good button I think I made an NRA joke
yeah uh don't you don't have to describe
it yeah doesn't it help if you just
well if I say it was just an NRA joke
then people can use their imagination
no no it's fine I think we're good do
you want a button no I'm I don't need a
button for I'm live eight to ten hours a
day I have my moments I I know but I
have my moments certainly but you know
when it comes to American dirt 911 yeah
I've Had My Moments like like you know
very very public moments right heated
gaming moments whatever but uh when I'm
on leftovers I'm I'm a lot you keep it
tight that's true I keep it tight
because I don't have a chat that's like
constantly trying to trigger me right
right well we do but you just ours is
more mild you think yours is more mild
it's mostly like thirsting and I love
that they're just thirsting for you yeah
I will I will peek into the I will peek
into the chat the YouTube chat and it's
just like oh my God can you guys stop
doing that
and can we ban comments on Hassan's
physical that's crazy
you you asked me to just shut off the
chat no well whatever it takes because
that one really all right listen Tim
pool uh continue with your uh genius
thesis here fire to spread isn't really
the issue because you make the fire
instantly in a bunch of different places
and they can monitor the weather in
Hawaii I mean you could just Google that
like what I was reading from the
national Guardsman who's making a
statement was that you know there's low
humidity and high winds that's perfect
conditions for wildfires to spread which
means any therefore there's space lasers
well you haven't seen the space laser
video yet you know what I love about
this right they've already agreed on the
space laser narrative they're just
saying like was it one space laser or
50. was it kind of a Dark Star situation
where it's multiple lasers combining
into a super laser of some sort uh that
is currently the argument that they're
engaging in it's about how many lasers
did they did they Deploy on Hawaii China
has a Death Star
yeah so the laser conspiracy comes from
uh I believe six months ago there was a
weather satellite that was engaging in
some level some kind of like mapping
here I'll throw it uh it was a Chinese
one yeah there it is
um let's take a look a rare view of the
green laser scan from space okay let's
see oh so so that like freaks
people out boom boom boom and they were
like oh this is definitely not coming
from space yeah yeah oh um I think
they were doing yeah I think they were
doing uh weather mapping like it's it's
very
like it's very open like they're not
it's not like a hidden thing we have
these satellites too so I don't know
listen I'm not a physicist but I would
imagine creating visible light
in the upper atmosphere it's a lot
easier than creating enough heat to
start a fire on the surface of the Earth
from space
can
can yes do we have lasers that can are
that strong in space
uh not on the books probably not on the
books we don't I mean we you know uh the
US military has done a lot of
development and Laser defense systems
yeah down InterContinental missiles
um so we definitely have lasers that can
melt and start fires but uh dude I
think it's about time we start you know
uh hey there's lots of trees in China
you know what I'm saying America what no
laser for laser I I dis about what
this I'm gonna say imaginaries like the
trees in China deer leader
Xi Jinping
I will take out this
counter-revolutionary do not worry
laser beams in outer space
starting foreign
that's like low-key the average American
mentality on this they're like oh they
definitely have lasers they definitely
use them in Hawaii and we have to fight
back by lasering okay can I ask you a
question what they're right is there a
chance that the Chinese actually lasered
Hawaii no like on a scale of like
one to a hundred well seeing as there is
footage of how the fire started and we
know we know what happened by the way
this is like a new Republic there's like
finally video evidence of it what about
the Chinese shot
the power line
okay right what's more likely uh oh we
have a capitalist capitalist utility
corporations that knew that uh high
winds were going to absolutely
eviscerate their power lines and did not
uh Harden their infrastructure
appropriately because they wanted to
ensure that they did not cut out
electricity to residential neighborhoods
so they put
why does it say San Diego Zoo Wildlife
Alliance
in the top right is that who filmed it
oh oh no this I think you know what this
is that a bird sanctuary in Hawaii and
so that Sanctuary is probably part of
the alliance and don't you think it's
just a little convenient that there
happens to be a camera in the middle of
the tropical jungle pointing right at
where well that's the uh
that's what they have to find it from
the San Diego Zoo Wildlife Alliance and
not like every person
and then uh later in the video because
the
because dropping the uh the laser uh
narrative for a moment uh basically yeah
this Transformer something blue and then
the camera went out for a minute and
then you see it kind of resetting here
and then by the time it gets back to
where well you can see that fire back
there yeah crazy
yeah those things yeah because those
things they just stay buzzing and look
at light whatever yeah so dry vegetation
is also I mean dry vegetation is a big
place Birds fared what oh don't bring up
how do you think the birds did there
dude come on what are you doing
you know you've seen the bird enclosure
they can't escape it's like a giant okay
okay all right think about it dude I eat
so much chicken every day and yet I'm
still hypocritical like because there's
a huge fire next to the giant bird gnome
and they're probably rare birds still
yeah
oh God are you rubbing it in okay listen
um
I'm gonna give you guys some additional
information that Washington Post has
probably not covered yet because I had
to do a little bit of a deeper dive into
what was going on in Hawaii because I
was covering all the conspiracy angles
and uh sorry can I stop you what
the birds are not rare
they're well done
go ahead sorry okay
so what
so what happened is uh this was even
before we got footage of the actual
power line falling
um that was the major speculation
because
uh Pelco Hawaiian electricity
corporation which is uh apparently not
very loved but they are the utility uh
they are the massive utility Giant in
Hawaii
um
in 2017
was already uh was already getting
criticized
for not modernizing its Grid in 2019
they got 200 million dollars to start
modernizing their grid mostly for uh you
know solar power incorporation but a
part of that modernization also
revolved around implementing
revolved around implementing strategies
for
um uh you know hardening the grid uh one
of the things that they looked at was
the uh campfire in 2018 which was
obviously the deadliest wildfire in
Mainland us that was my hometown Ventura
right that was that one
um yeah I think
the campfire was that up north that was
the one up north the event was really
bad too though but yeah it was the worst
one so
so campfire was the was the worst one
before the the wildfires in Lahaina and
um they knew that a big part A major
component of how wildfires start is when
power lines are downed due to either
winds or due to excessive vegetation uh
that you haven't uh maintained that
you're supposed to that you get billions
of dollars from the federal government
usually or the state government to to
upkeep
and um one technique that they utilized
in San Diego was uh like automatically
uh engaging in a surge protection that
cuts off electricity in the uh I guess
1.37 seconds that it takes for a power
line to fall into the ground interesting
wow um and uh
they they petitioned it like one of
these like Wildlife Hawaiian foundations
um actually
sent a request to hellco asking them if
they were utilizing the surge protection
and they were like oh it's just too new
technology we haven't really implemented
it we'll we'll think about it
so something like that would have
actually prevented this Wildfire from
spreading or even starting if they had
like uh adequate surge protection
so are you saying corporations are the
bad guys is this a private owned or or
well all utilities are are basically
they're a functional Monopoly but they
are privately owned and operated
[Music]
usually this would have never happened
in a socialist country probably
I mean
you can always have mismanagement it
happens
it's about where the mismanagement is
coming from
is it mismanagement due to bureaucratic
incompetence or is it mismanagement due
to profit seeking uh you know cost
Cutting Corner cutting measures that
you're implementing when people are
telling you well I know this is not
profitable but we have to harden this
infrastructure because later down the
line many lives could be lost
oftentimes with utilities both in
California as we know PG e being one of
the major uh villains in California
during Wildfire season or in general
um
utility Corporation utility uh
utility companies will always cut
Corners when they are not supposed to
they will get subsidies from the federal
government they'll get subsidies from
the state government the infrastructure
that they're relying on is already built
by uh you know local governments and and
yet
uh they'll take these uh tax breaks
subsidies and even sometimes like yeah
yeah Direct Cash infusions and they will
engage in stock BuyBacks and and refuse
to actually Implement safety measures
that they claimed they were going to
with the money sounds fair I mean
they're going to go to jail right
what the is that
yeah that's why there's no fires that's
in Maryland that's crazy they actually
were trying to laser Tim all right let's
move on thank you but uh our hearts go
out to the Hawaiians it's tragic it's
horrible and uh
protects your right to own nuclear
weapons
or should I say the Chinese government
to be more specific because we love chat
we love the Chinese Americans don't we
folks I love the Chinese Americans and
the government I love both you are a
cheese Tim
uh Iowa State Fair this is a big deal
and the presidential president Terry
primary
yeah everybody's going to show face and
show what uh how they can mix it up with
the commoners for example
uh pants
pasty Pence
here he is getting pretty pasty isn't he
yeah it's pretty good right yeah here he
is getting heckled by Trump supporter
that the Iowa fair
he is not a Christian when you say
higher power
you know if Mike Pence isn't a Christian
then Jesus ain't a Christian okay I love
Bryce's I love the angle of attack
here of being like I'm a trump supporter
and you Mike Pence are no real Christian
Trump is that's right like what's
happening there the law of your mind
hang him
his name is Barbara which I love because
I always automatically assign the name
Barbara or Debra to ladies like that
yeah she's wearing a back-to-back Iowa
caucus or back-to-back Iowa Champions
hat which is really interesting that's
what the the Trump supporters were
giving out that's what the Trump team
was handing out and I find that
particularly interesting because Trump
lost Iowa to Ted Cruz really that's
pretty rough so I I guess he means like
in the general General yeah oh whoa whoa
whoa this guy is not wearing Grateful
Dead
I'm sorry you can't be you can't be at
the Iowa fair he's wearing an Iowa City
Yacht Club Grateful Dead merch dude that
is that is not what they were about man
how many Yachts are in Iowa
um Iowa landlog at least one
probably yeah
yeah you buy closely you think they
can't yacht in Lakes crank us they can
and take it back
what did he say he's saying I'm glad
that I'm glad they didn't hang him
people actually say that I was kidding
no no that's that's the most vocal Mike
Pence supporter yeah no he this is this
is him getting a little bit low yeah you
know that's the biggest phrase he can
get he's just quiet you weren't murdered
yeah and finally said yeah you know I I
was in favor of it but I realized I was
wrong I can really see uh Jerry Garcia
calling for the hanging of public
officials it's right on the message for
them yeah I mean
take that shirt off dude I don't think I
don't think that guy is like a deadhead
I I think he just probably bought the
merch you think so yeah he's like I got
a yacht maybe you're right I got a pound
they probably just ripped that from the
internet and yeah shame on them
so they're glad that Mike Pence did not
get hanged uh by the crowd so that's Pro
I think that's progress
if that's good for his campaign he's not
really they're really warming up for him
to him uh DeSantis was down there
actually
um on the bumper cards no uh bumper cars
no less uh very exciting very down to
earth
wait I didn't see this oh my God yeah a
rare DeSantis moment he escaped you know
what he's doing here he's pretending
he's on a border uh Street and just take
it out
immigrant families running across the
border dude you know he is very
cartoonish in the way that his like face
moves right
like he always gets like ah oh he'll do
that and I think that there's nothing
more cartoony than getting on a
bumper car so I guess he's not beating
the Looney Tune allegations but he's
also just leaning into it kind of but
let's see new Ron let's see let's see so
an important detail about this video I
should point out is that they shut down
the ride I guess probably for security
concerns so it's just him and his wife
with a crowd of people that's so down to
earth there's something so
[Music]
all the little kids are just like
watching and crying they're like why
can't I play and Ron's like it's my time
God he's such a freak
[Music]
let's go
yeah
look how excited his daughter is she
hasn't hung out with her dad like this
you know like the footsteps did I cut
that no we love him we love the kids
don't we
[Music]
all look at him go oh they both do you
see that
he smiled
here he comes
[Music]
he's having so much fun it's so
uncomfortable to just like do this
without all these without any of the
other cars around and all these people
are watching you it's a death match bro
1v1
and just cameras recording yeah
yo by the way he is destroying his wife
like he is out she is terrible at bumper
cars what is she doing he's taking her
to the mats with this man yeah get the
out of here
so there it is very down to earth and uh
that's Governor de Santa That's nowhere
near as bad I've seen uh
I've seen way worse photos opposed to
one on my Instagram like there's there's
a lot of really horrible photos of him
he always like stands so awkwardly with
his hands like planted to his side it's
it's it's dope oh he's got some new
boots
he's got new boots yeah you remember the
face yeah
he's back he's in cowboy boots now yeah
he's a he's cowboy in it you know like
in Florida do is that a Florida thing
that's not really a Florida thing is it
they're my boy boots brother it's it's
whatever you want it to be okay I need
some good old swamp Walkers it doesn't
even matter like these guys they
Ron DeSantis like didn't you go to
hardwood Harvard and Yale I
think like we used to put on cowboy
boots rock around campus all fake so did
Ted Cruz you know it's all fake it's
just like yeah look at me I'm so rugged
down to earth and you see uh how awful
and nice
he cannot be serious right now this man
is sitting there in a suit with cowboy
boots that's not real did this really
happen I just saw it right before the
show so uh this is even worse
potentially than the white boots
well that's insane hold on hold on did
you show up to a meeting on ironically
like this um
I'm trying to find what it's from right
now what a weirdo man
here he is here's Ron DeSantis uh chat
chanting
walk through a crowd chanting we love
Trump we want Trump oh that's gotta hurt
let's see
Santi pie Santi claws
they love you man going great for you
[Applause]
yeah nobody's even shaking his hand bro
he's trying to shake hands nobody wants
to have anything to do with them
look at him It's gotta it's weird look
at him he's found he's forcing people he
literally grabbed that guy's hand in the
red it's so weird It's gotta be weird
look at this he's like give me a
handshake crowd
holy man you are ruined dude
listen I uh I don't think he's gonna do
well in Iowa
it's not looking good I want to see did
this man put out his hand or did the
Santa's grab it
it takes place behind his wife
but once again I don't understand this
that guy's hand is fully down yeah you
could see it yeah yeah here it is
yeah and I think that's the handy shakes
he's not interested at all
now here it comes here he comes
okay he's like yo yo yo yo
this is desantis's hand yeah reaching
fist bumping it's like trying to fist
bump him maybe someone else keep going
yeah no they they did a really weird
Shake because he did and he's like
thanks bro he's like I don't I don't
care about you oh no he wanted it on my
shoulder no he went up for a handshake
he wasn't even looking at him he did a
shoulder yeah yeah I think that's it
he's not even looking at the Santas he's
like why are you touching me bro
it's awesome he's the best and oh that's
the one yep I love that dude this is
powerful
when you nut and she keeps sucking
please clap this is oh it's so bad
stop it and finally getting the best
head right now
finally uh the Dark Horse vivik
ramaswamy
is rapping which is I mean you know Down
to Earth as it gets
uh he's in second now I believe and he's
crazy but he's uh Rising as DeSantis
Falls and will likely pass him this man
is a loony tune he is uh I would say
he's more
he is like the Andrew Yang style
candidate and I'm not saying that
because they're both Asian well I don't
even think that bro why would you even
bring that up uh well I'm gonna bring a
part of that up in a second
um like why that's relevant especially
in the Republican primary in a brief
moment but
um he is very like he knows what
messaging to try he knows what messaging
will work
uh he's really hitting the high notes
like he was a big like anti-woke Warrior
you know culture Warrior early on as
I've told you guys before he uh
he he was working on finding a cure for
cancer but then his uh during the George
Floyd protest like his company was like
we love black lives matter so he was
like oh no my company's gone woke
I no longer want to find the cure to
cancer so we quit you think what you
think he was right there no so he
quit finding the cure to cancer
and instead went and uh you know decided
to I guess invest in companies that are
not woke and then wrote a book about it
right yep is that his book yeah this is
his book yeah he was like I'm gonna I'm
gonna fund non-woke companies
he's such a weird character I mean he's
super smart super super smart super
Savvy businessman but he is a weird
I think he would come on
this show I've tried we've tried
reaching out haven't we Olivia
uh Olivia did reach out uh last week uh
I don't think we've heard back why is
Vivek ramaswamy afraid of having a
logical conversation
maybe he did I shouldn't speak for her
she's uh I think taking care of Kaya
right now so I'll continue we'll
continue to press him to come on the
show I I I honoronically think we could
have a really interesting conversation
with them yeah I mean he he also had
like a big own when he talked to like a
pansexual uh person at the Iowa State
Fair they found the the one pansexual in
Iowa
what did he tell them
um she was like
what do you think about like uh you know
what's your policies on gender and
sexuality LGBT and he hit like the
dumbest talking point but everyone on
the Republican side was glazing him
saying like oh my God he's so brilliant
um this part is really funny actually so
let's just watch that this unironically
looks way cooler don't you have those I
feel like I don't have the Croc ones I
have the red ones the original one I
feel like you would get the Croc ones I
wish I had the Croc ones I didn't get
them aren't they hard to put on the red
ones extremely hard to put on extremely
uncomfortable very very very uh
stupid not a day to day yeah not a day
today but I think it's cool as a art
project like we just we have it up as a
Decor as a decorative art piece
uh here what did you want me to watch
let's watch this and then we'll talk
about his Ownage
bro you are not doing Eminem right now
sure is yes he is dude wait wait are we
gonna get claimed did we check this uh
yeah it didn't get claimed I mean it I
don't want to say 100 I think if we just
watch a second of it because he's
getting happy everybody's joking now
you're mostly just hearing his voice
so he didn't even rewrite the lyrics no
he's just performing Lose Yourself no he
he's
hitting the nose he's the greatest white
boy to ever
God did well apparently apparently he
used to rap in college too I know that I
know that about him but he used to like
Freestyle or do his own raps I
understand why he's coming and
Performing Eminem this is his favorite
there is a video of him in college
performing the song uh I think this is
just kind of like this is his go-to
karaoke song basically okay yeah
swag rizzed up I can't watch this
this is harder to watch them I love
thinking about like an Iowa farmer
okay who's just there just absolute
Trump supporter two terms still thinks
Trump is the president okay sitting
there watching
a brown man
sing and like rap out Eminem and being
like yeah this is he's gonna do it for
me I think I'm voting for this Vivek
fella
he's going up in the polls he is going
up in the polls because he is actually
like you said very smart
um I think he he knows he's got strong
rhetoric he's definitely more
charismatic than Ronald uh McDonald
DeSantis and
um however
at the end of the day no matter how well
you can debate
if you are uh a brown man
running in the Republican primaries
there is a very active base of support
within the Republican constituency that
looks at you and goes oh no way that's
uh either a terrorist or no way he
worships cows I am not voting for that
that is anti-christian that is literally
satanic well they're right on one count
he is a terrorist just to Eminem's music
well he well he's a terrorist in the
sense that every Republican is in my
opinion they're way more successful at
doing acts of Terror than than Isis or
Al Qaeda ever could be but we have
actually breaking live news right now
Lindell is dropping his Truth uh bomb
should we pull that up do you think or
should we let's watch this video I don't
want to miss it oh boy should we pull up
Mike Lindell so I just listened in uh I
was watching they have a big counter on
stage and um it got to
it got to zero but this guy isn't done
doing his ad yet so they're letting him
finish up
all right let me let's watch this it
looks like he's wrapping up now let's
watch Vivek own this Panther how many
people are watching uh well here on
YouTube we have six thousand no and he's
also simulcasting on Rumble Frank
speech.com and uh a few other places
this man spent his last dollars
yeah he's uh you see Lindell
offensefund.org he needs money he's
desperately I I he's stopped between
pretty much every segment he's ran out
of staplers and office papers so you're
right yeah all right so here's Vivek
owning
I don't know should we watch that is he
about that I mean it's happening right
now yeah yeah he just he here he is
you are the biggest
should we set up Brook ladies promo in
my pillow 25 languages hold on just full
screen it
and would you like me to set this up
real quick for the audience
because the thing no actually he's not
proving that the election's stolen he's
revealing a plan given to him by God uh
of how to save our elections in this
country oh so he's given up trying to
okay okay
exciting here it is here's the plan that
they can spread the word that they can
spread the word that's the answer this
is the Hope we've been waiting for Jesus
we pray that every part that people
understand that people really doesn't
end well man
we pray
we have nothing
it's over
and Lord we thank you I thank you Lord
for every part of this for every person
every person that's been part of this
for every person that is uh in our
country
our country that they can be told that
hey we have we have secure our elections
our sacred elections how much money did
Michael
he was worth like 200 million dollars at
a point Jesus Christ okay we got a
little bit of setup here's Jeff what the
oh my God still is the here's the
plan the plans on that laptop it's all
happening right now the plans coming
down the HDMI cable right now at
franksbeach.com and get 20 off my pillow
has 6 000 people watching it to be
honest I thought it'd be like a thousand
well how many are on Friends bro that is
crazy no like right side broadcasting at
Peak of like
at the peak of Trump's popularity these
guys will get like 50k no matter what
damn I mean falling off
yeah I think Mike is doing like a sunk
cost fallacy at this point because um
he's in like 150 million I'm telling you
all we've been told a lie over over
years now go on that the machines are
not on the internet huh if anybody just
watching that just tuned in now to Frank
speech aren't on the Internet or any of
the other networks that are running this
and um
languages we went over the biggest slide
we've been told that's blocked all of
our cyber evidence and everything I'm so
privileged to be watching this live on
the internet we're
we're not on the internet
sorry there's not there's nothing to see
here we're not on the internet
by ever
oh there's the audio went out no no not
now Mike no other
in our country has also been told around
the world to their countries
these electronic voting machines from
routers to printers
they're not online what was it isn't he
like gas
for a lot of money
I believe so they already semantic or
maybe both I forget this is going to
play well for him in court that that
machine was online
yo yo yo get up to a thousand dollars
ten thousand dollars in Precious Metals
for free you guys I love Precious Metals
with a qualifying purchase and then you
have to have passwords and so on I've
never seen that that's high if you've
got one of those again what if there was
advice that showed you it's a good deal
there's a device on my network
sbn2298-9988 what the device was where
it was at what the name of it was what
is the plan 503 and you knew that he's
still talking about the old yeah
that's what I'm saying and this is day
two of his conference yesterday it was
over 12 hours I actually don't even know
how long it went because even uh right
this this channel they cut it off after
12 hours I only I only get my my
Glendale information from you guys I I
don't even follow them that close it's
my favorite Ian can you do me a favor
just zoom in on this head of Santa Claus
Florida
um
with this device we went in and we uh we
did uh Jeff will show you that once
you're sure
ready to go
or Wireless monitoring device wait it's
a DTS sound monitoring device is a
sophisticated network connection
monitoring system designs specifically
the decoration Security in mind
yeah
this is this is
a message
Wi-Fi connections in county and state
election offices all internet routers
and access points okay
to which they connect bro they didn't
even get up they didn't get a slow-mo
camera for many years of research and
state-of-the-art development
network operations
when an online connection is detected
the election crime Bureau Master System
will be quickly notified and the alert
will be displayed on the alert web page
[Music]
these boxes display the information
about the access points at the top and
the wireless clients at the bottom box
what
wait I don't know what is happening he
it looks like he built an improvised
explosive device and he's going to blow
every it looks like he's gonna blow up
every poem analyzing the map difficult
so this is unveiling is yeah it's like
oh if you're if you're 65 year old aunt
who's like a poll worker uh accessed
Facebook during the during the counting
process we will kill her with this
explosive device those types of devices
are removed from the map and it will
make a big mushroom cloud like
Oppenheimer to displays additional
information about the device in the
bottom information
some kind of spy device into polling
stations
Wi-Fi access points that's for sure it's
probably illegal and it's probably just
a scheme for him to sell this thing to
his
UMD detection group followers you know
okay okay so no no this is this is a
Madman okay this is a man who's like
hallucinating because like everybody
needs a pillow dog like people need a
pillow you need to you're gonna go to
sleep you want a pillow you need a
pillow that's a that's a product that
like you can sell this is a product with
an incredibly Niche audience let me tell
you everybody turn it up we now can
catch them in a lot
[Applause]
rsbn.locals.com guys uh hold that
thought okay exclusive content 24 7
interactive live chat like-minded
community and also behind the scenes hit
the join button it's a video how
they gonna hit the join button wait wait
they're gonna they're testing you right
now everybody
here it is
flying this drone into an active pulling
location yeah this is this
foreign
[Music]
location
that's it
I know drones can do that no it died out
no I think it they lost connection no no
here it comes so is this
it's literally flying Ethan it's flying
it
oh my God it can fly everybody special
delivery he said we're gonna we're gonna
deploy these wmds in polling stations
with drones frankly I think the idea of
just going like full Isis bombing them
it makes more sense than whatever this
is I just don't here's what I don't
understand which I don't condone or
recommend yeah I have nothing to do
here's what I don't understand
who has enough money to purchase this
equipment or the technical know-how to
like deploy it up here by the way
another thing I still don't understand
really what it is
remove the Drone please thank you
Samantha this device
Mike Mike Mike
I'm so excited I forget to use a micron
yeah you're killing it you guys
this device as it flew into the ground
listen he's such a show Wireless
monitoring device it just grabbed all of
your cell phones everybody in this room
every device that's for sure not right
now and let's see can you put it up on
the big screen wait no he's not gonna
die he's like
I have just stole all of your credit
card numbers this does when this gathers
information
there's a command center with this
information like that goes down it
flashes it'll go
Missouri right it goes there it comes
back and and now here's what just came
in as we came into the building here you
see all the cell phones there all the
computers
no this is this is now can you like
people who are up a little like hackers
and like this is It's sniffing
networks in a vicinity in its vicinity
that's like cell phones others
what the okay everybody doing this
is as I go
as a culture imagine he's finally
arrested election night now we already
know we were showing you that there's no
device in the world that does what this
does okay it does it is to catch cap is
passively captured but it's now it's
going to tell you which device so he
just took out all the cell phones
depending on what level of information
it can capture it could either be
illegal or it could be just basically
like one big telephone that can see
every Wi-Fi like this is a Wi-Fi network
yeah like it can be but cell phones
don't okay no your cell phones can pick
up yourself will pick up like all the
Wi-Fi access points though
he's saying he's picking up cell phones
we didn't want to take the chance we
could have got some machines
this is weird we had them we were we had
access
see what happens
I didn't want to take that chance this
is not a shame for the world okay I'm
telling you what we can do now if you're
in a room and you're hearing Springfield
Missouri and you're in this room and
this is an election room beep beep beep
router just went online this red alert
goes out there boom and I'll tell you in
a minute okay
because he's very hung up on uh on the
voting machines being connected to the
internet and that's how they they log in
and change all the votes and so he wants
I'm suspecting his followers to buy this
drone from him fly it into voting fly it
into I don't know why the Drone is
necessary to be quite honest sick
you could just walk in with it right
yeah but it's dope so fly a drone into a
voting into an active voting place and
sniff the Wi-Fi access points to see if
the voting machine is on the Wi-Fi I
think
[Music]
Mississippi Kentucky you have local
elections anyone that has this I mean
everyone that has an election we don't
get it these yokis in the audience
aren't going to get it action yeah I've
been watching uh and you know what
you're watching this
you lied to me and uh so what so so Jeff
I want you to explain okay we've been
cutting to the Giants
up to 60 off everything use the promo
code rsbn
66 off everything oh my bad
Everything Must Go
like really
did you pause it really got it yeah I
paused it why would you do that yeah it
will show the IP address uh it wasn't
sure if it was gonna cut away what's
called a MAC address which is like the
hardware uh identification of it and
we'll also show what it's named on the
internet
will we know the brand yeah
we will actually
I noticed too that surely can't be legal
uh polling books it doesn't matter it
will know exactly uh we can identify
remember now so let's see there is a
statute here it says the federal wiretap
statute prohibits sniffing of contents
of communication by a device unless the
contents are readily accessed to the
general public yeah depending on that's
why I say depending on what level of
information because they can pull their
IPs so you had people in there by the
way yeah I don't think that's no I don't
think that's legal no shot
what this is no if you can see like if
you can if you can be in an area and
like your phone picks up you know
Wireless uh access points that's one
thing right or like printers for example
or computers that is like
accessible via your phone that's one
thing if it's like looking at I think
the IP is right
I don't think that's public in most
cases well I I kind of just wanted to if
you don't mind uh point out one of the
excitements
on a sex offender's list now that we've
got that out of the way
us know when devices when new devices
come online uh and and we in real time
real time crime and this thing can even
send out text messages
like selling this product yeah I agree
that's selling the product because
they're so incompetent I doubt that
they're capable of like crafting and and
uh selling
a device that legitimately is like uh
hey stealing information from all the
networks in a vicinity but we're not
online shut her down right yeah and uh
the IP thing is is not that big of a
deal either somebody in the chat said
it's basically this thing called a Wi-Fi
pineapple
um which from what I understand is legal
it does have some features that would be
illegal but it just depends on how it's
utilized basically I'm not sure let me
tell you what they have in this other in
store here
so it might not be illegal but I think
flying a drone into a polling place
probably is illegal that's yeah there's
that's that's regulated actually yes
that seems not and imagine a boomer
behind the controls of that thing
slicing into people
um all right Mike what are you saying
one alert this is a red alert a red
alert okay that the machines went online
right so if you're a clerk or if you're
all of us know all of you at home you
don't want to know this too right well
we've had whistleblower sites who've had
just like I told you I think yesterday
or today when Carrie Lakes the race was
going on and all those machines broke
there they said they were broke down in
Missouri I mean in uh Arizona just
riffing I think I'm looking at Kansas
going people are sending me texts going
Mike they're these votes are going from
Democrats to Republicans you know I mean
you know the inner party member okay
now he's playing the same old
like the highlights yeah
the election crime Bureau I love that
this guy is so broke that he is hired
like he he does not have a graphics
designer he's going to his like 14 whoa
oh whoa what's going on holy
ladies and gentlemen this is this is not
an election station and yet for some
reason the Michael Lindell drone is
sniffing our packets it's stealing rips
folks what is happening oh oh my god oh
oh Jesus
damn thank you Dan wow that was scary
it almost got my
IP address
your package season
it'll sniff your pockets then it'll
stiff your
send me both I mean I guess it's like
cool that the grift is Advanced from
just like selling you iodine pills
right selling you a very expensive drone
no and a Wi-Fi pineapple you guys were
saying uh yeah that uh I don't know if
it's exactly that if they just made
their own or what but somebody in the
chat said it they think that's what it
is and I looked it up and it seems like
it's just kind of like a general device
that can do a lot of stuff does this man
have children it's gonna reveal the plan
we'll save our elect
forms he's God's child something that's
never been done the Lions industry
we talked about for that matter everyone
whether you're a republic
[Music]
he's trying to farm the Democrats I'm a
democratic Michael Lindell supporter ask
me anything we have amazing lineup
check out check it out General Flynn
um
this is actually an amazing lineup
because this is like basic blues first
of all a good healthy third of these
people are currently indicted okay right
like I just want to point that out
really quickly uh the other half is uh
absolutely under civil litigation they
are being sued successfully by the likes
of dominion and and others do you want
to donate
I definitely don't want to donate it
says Lindell legal offense fund Inc is
not a charitable quantities
I mean if that's all I thought I
suggested
this is not a charitable organization
I'm glad that these are not tax
deductible I'm glad they have the 50 000
like you know clickable button because
it's like I'm always trying to get that
conveniently I don't want to type in I'm
always trying to donate fifty thousand
dollars the click of a button I want to
go to other that button I mean how many
that's six dig seven if you include the
comma that do you do you think that
that is like
they can accidentally get a boomer to
miss click and then just like Farm them
definitely yeah fraud but
we're gonna send a sniffer so wow that
was that was beautiful
um carbon monoxide that that lineup that
you saw the Michael Linda lineup that
you saw earlier if we can go back to
that I don't know if you're sure yeah I
can pull it back up um that is basically
Trump's last line of defense
some of which are his co-defendants uh
which is not good because they are going
to turn on him in my opinion
for example there is uh currently some
drama going on with one of the
co-defendants in the RICO case in
Georgia Janet Ellis who
swap size went from Donald Trump to Ron
DeSantis and been a DeSantis loyalist
for some time now and Laura Loomer who
you can see right next to Steve Bannon
Laura Loomer of course is a big time
Trump loyalist uh was at the Bedminster
Golf Course recently took some photos
with Donald Trump really funny ones but
um she has been ripping into Jenna Ellis
because Jenna Ellis is asking for money
begging for money on the timeline for
her legal defense
because a lot of the co-defendants that
uh that they nabbed alongside Trump in
many of these cases both in federal and
also in Georgia State Court
they do not have money and Trump is not
defending them he's not giving them
money for their legal counsel
which makes the situation extra funny
because like then they're absolutely
gonna flip on them right
I think so yeah they're all I mean why
would any of them fall on the sword for
him I don't know Rudy Giuliani is
another guy Rudy's he doesn't give a
about anyone but those big tits
coming over here yeah
big time Big Tits um you see those
here's a definitely wait this is
definitely edited this is definitely
yeah not a real photo of Donald that's a
unit man it's not
pull go up who posted this
huh who posted this I don't know some
random account is this the bottom half
of this image is AI generated is it
that's what it says on the fact check
here here's the uh here Laura posted
this
this is the original image it is so that
part is
Wait no that's I think Laura Loomer cut
the image out as she you think she
cropped it I think she cropped it you
think this is real
I don't know look well I mean I that's
not a real body look I've seen Trump's
dumpy so many times
I I miss it I don't know what it looks
like nowadays
it is edited okay so is that one edited
he looks really Slim there yeah he's
he's been he's been getting Alexander
and hot so wait do you think extremely
wet his torso looks really small you
think they edited this one no uh that is
called being fat and pulling your your
belt all the way up your belly so you
can hide how big your belly is right
yeah I I listen as a fat guy former fat
guy yeah you're Ethan now own it just
Ethan
except the problem is you have to wear a
jacket over it because otherwise you
just you ain't fooling nobody like no
one's looking at you and going wow like
I generally I'm looking at him and
thinking he looks pretty good no no he
has lost weight for sure good for you
good for you Mr President oh God Laura
Loomer I do effort posting on Twitter is
so silly who's reading this look at this
I mean how many likes is average with
Trump it's probably a banger nobody okay
nobody read this though they liked it
for the picture yeah she is she is like
ripping into so she's ripping the Jenna
Ellis and other people that are like no
longer on the Trump Camp right now um
yeah they're rhinos they're fake they're
phony what do you think he's pointing to
like what's out there
I don't maybe his wife his dad's wife
you know the dead gray
is further down the line you can't find
it because it's covered in shrubbery now
that
it's my favorite game we play a hole in
one on that bitch's grave I buried her I
buried her like she tried to bury me in
litigation
hahaha
okay let's go back to Vivek uh Benny
Johnson so uh
Ben or Vivek owned a pansexual person
yes Benny Johnson of course who is the
but it wasn't even an Ownage well quote
unquote on but then the quote unquote is
also around pansexual like it's fake
Benny you're gay and I didn't want to
say why are you I will say it not only
is he gay everybody knows he's gay like
it's like a known thing in conservative
circles that I've said time and time
again Benny Johnson is not allowed to go
on trips by himself without his wife
present any longer because he
dudes on the side I had the gay cruise
ad yeah he's the one who also had the
gay cruise ad
on the military website he's like why
are they showing me gay cruise ads on
military.com so anyway Benny posted this
let's take a look
okay well I don't think it's one
Community yeah I mean how could it be
just Mash together an alphabet soup
trans is fundamentally intention with
gay if you ask me but what's your
opinion
wait first pause it so he first he does
the classic British technique which is
uh it's not LGBT love it's LGB the t is
different which is like uh not something
that like Americans give a about
because if they genuinely have an
opinion
it's usually like yeah they're all
immoral perverts who are definitely
going to hell and and you know satanic
or on the other side the the the average
American just like maybe thinks they're
like weird and and gross but overall
like doesn't give a enough you know
what I mean and then you of course have
people who are supporters
um
but he's trying to do that he's trying
to make that distinction stick which uh
hasn't really worked in America it has
worked in the UK because they are
uniquely transphobic but
doesn't really work in America but let's
move on hold on this member
Haiti
says I'm pansexual and oh oh
oh Iowan
so we found her we found it ladies and
gentlemen we got her I was joking
obviously I'm sure there's plenty of
pansexuals in Iowa
all right so here is Benny boy or I mean
pansexual so I was just wondering what
your views on same-sex couples were I
don't have a negative view of same-sex
couples but I do
all right it so here's the no no
wait wait wait wait wait no you gotta
hear the bar what do you think because
well he's at first like trans people
they are not part of this community yeah
okay so how do you feel about the
community without the trans people hate
him no no he goes I don't have a
negative view at all but no no listen no
he said I have a negative view no oh I
don't have a negative view watch the
bars that come after this though because
it's so stupid it gave me an
aneurysm when I saw it yesterday all
right misheard him let's Ugg went back a
little bit
a negative he literally that I would
have a negative no I don't have a
negative view Ethan that's what he's
saying but just why would he I don't
have anything no I don't have negative
view I heard it that time guys I heard
it yeah but keep going I heard it you
are you got there people Goblin mode
today your your Goblin mode look how
many times you paused him I'm trying
y'all
like I'm the only one you're always
positive every five seconds I just want
to watch Vivek spit bro
of a tyranny of the minority so so I
think that in the name of protecting
against the tyranny of the majority and
there are times in this country's
history where we have had a tyranny of
the majority
we have now the name of democracy first
of all the tyranny of majority a
terrifying Prospect democracy
the fact that this says
LGBT rights are the tyranny of minority
is insane because
and obviously this person uh is not like
trying to have a debate with him at that
moment she's just trying to figure out
what his opinions are
75 of the country believes in protecting
safe sex same-sex marriage what the
do you mean a tyranny of minority well
that is not a minority
the minority is the 25 Evangelical
Protestants who are like No actually
that's demon and they're all
pedophiles and they need to go to hell
and and they can't get married that's
the tyranny of minority the Republican
party's entire strategy revolves around
implementing The Tyranny minority they
don't even hide it they often will
openly state that by saying the tyranny
of majority America was founded on
eliminating interior majority that's why
they have the Electoral College this is
not a real democracy this is a this is a
constitutional republic sir like that's
that's a republican line so very odd for
him to take this position and doubly odd
that Republicans were like glazing him
saying he he did such a good job who who
is he speaking for exactly he's asking
someone who's part of the LGBT community
and he's like no trans people they don't
belong trust me it's like whoa
did you well you're talking to a member
of the LGBT she disagrees so who are you
speaking for Benny Johnson also like
yeah are you gay like what the do
you know what the yeah exactly who
are you speaking for
maybe maybe people to Obama and he
imagined having sex with men in his
dreams in order to raise up some
bisexual Marxist Queens in college
and too all right I'm gonna play
it now I'm gonna play it any of the
majority created a new tyranny of the
minority and I think that that's wrong I
don't think that somebody who's
religious should be forced to officiate
a wedding that they disagree with hold
on that's not happening it's not
nobody's being forced to officiate
weddings no but but Republicans love
making fake uh problems cry about no
there is one aspect of this uh that
Republicans uh often point to which is
uh churches still get
subsidies for adoption programs for
example and they are a major network of
you know adoption providers in this
country and uh same-sex couples have to
by law be allowed to adopt at the church
adoption programs and uh if they don't
abide by it which they can still refuse
they won't get any federal subsidies so
that's like a big point of contention
without officiating but yeah the
officiating of weddings I'm just making
sure is is I don't know how that works
uh I don't I don't know why he's like uh
there is there's the gays are forcing us
good Christians to officially like what
what gay couples like I want to go to a
Baptist Church in the in the
heart of the South where they're doing
like snake charming and get gay married
there you know what I mean by the way
we've been crunching the numbers on
Mike's logo
election crime Bureau we located this
uh this is we located this on PNG tree
security Shield Red Eagle logo design
template Vector oh yeah and actually
totally fine lifetime you can get the
lifetime license for
uh 129 actually yeah
so I could be wrong about uh I don't
want to speak for uh Mr ramaswamy over
here but
this is I suspect what he's referring to
with this which this is a judge getting
in trouble
for
refusing to officiate a wedding which is
totally a different thing
right okay now that's a really
illegal okay you can't do that let me
read this uh headline for you guys Texas
judge who doesn't want to perform gay
marriage ceremonies hopes web designers
Supreme Court case helps her fight right
because that's your legal obligation yup
you cannot do that so I don't know for
sure this is what he's referring to but
this is the first thing forced to
officiate gay wedding I Google that and
this comes up from just last month uh so
I'm pretty sure that this is okay what
he sort of referenced because gay
marriage is not about churches uh even
though uh conservatives love talking
about it from the Anglo churches it's
about certification it's a legal it's a
legal thing Roberto fell is is basically
creating an uh a structure where like
States and all matter of Courts have to
legally recognize and certify uh
same-sex uh couples right
I'm really I had no idea
I don't think somebody who is a woman
who's worked really hard for her
achievements should be forced to compete
against a biological man
immediately hits the trans women in uh
in sports competing against his women
line would you just asked wasn't the
question at all yeah where are you going
yeah because you can't because Vivi my
boy that is the only
sound bite that actually has some level
they've tested this out as you know as
well they focus grouped this and they
found that as long as you tie it like as
long as you tie anti-trans rhetoric uh
not directly to like utilizing bathrooms
or whatever which is unsuccessful but to
an element of fairness which actually
does penetrate the American
Consciousness fairly well that's
actually a prescient message that people
cling onto which is why the discourse
has moved into
like dunking on the three trans girls at
the swim meet in the entire
state of Kansas it's like so stupid
who cares you let's let's play it
okay mute our mics okay
gladly
we're both muted
we're locked in I don't think that
somebody who's a woman
yeah
nope
specs or bodily autonomy and dignity
should be forced to change clothes in a
locker room with a man that's not
Freedom that's oppression and so I
believe that we live in a country where
free adults should be free to address
how they want behave how they want
that's fine but you don't oppress you
don't become oppressive by foisting that
on others and that especially includes
kids because kids aren't the same as
adults and so I think adults are free to
make whatever choices they want
but do not voice that ideology onto
children before children are in a
position as adults to make decisions for
themselves
there's a lot of the frustration in the
country and if I'm being really honest
that I also share comes from being
really honest culture of Oppression
where saying those things can actually
get somebody punished
and in my case it's part of why it's my
responsibility to say them and I respect
that you may have a different opinion
and that's okay part of what makes our
country great is that you and I can
be civil and have this conversation and
that we live in a country that still
gives us each of us the right to speak
into a presidential
stealing this content you're not
reacting to it hard enough but yeah
we're gonna call it now man okay I just
want to say how beautiful this country
is that I can openly wish for your uh
genocide
yeah it's like it's beautiful to have
that kind of Freedom yeah it's it's
beautiful to live in a country where you
can say that it's tyrannical for like
trans women to coexist in society
it's so wonderful and then also act out
sorry
what love said he supports genocide I
didn't threw me off
um also act out the the uh act out those
Desires in your legislative agenda which
genuinely does uh harm trans people
all right eating food it's there's a few
Pebbles there for uh it's a big deal
yeah
um we better move on because we are
running out of time okay what is my can
we cut to micro fast
uh I just want to see if he's still
um going on he's he is still going on
let me just hear him for like 30 seconds
you love him so much I'm just yeah yeah
all right let's check oh he brought
someone new yeah you guys need to
understand she doesn't disengage this is
so important boring I had all these
groups I call every Monday night I talk
to the whole country which goes out to a
quarter Millions but you talk to I
talked to all the leaders who are going
and we sit there and we have fun we have
fun with lawsuits we have fought with
with canvassing we've thought we've
probably put petitions you name it we've
done it all right thank you all right
thanks Mike we'll check back in thanks
Mike we'll check back in on him we got
to talk about Crowder yeah we gotta talk
about Crowder so um are you aware of the
cheating rumors
with Crowder no it has to be with a man
right there's no women three
different women it's a like Crowder yeah
you hadn't heard about this at all right
no this is news to me the fact that you
haven't heard about it is what makes the
story so interesting yeah because
because Crowder has fallen off so
cataclysmically that I don't think
people even pay attention to him at all
so let me kind of take you through this
Wormhole okay I love this so on
Crowder's show
he's addressing the allegations the
allegations that we all expect to be
addressing is that he's showing his dick
to everybody yeah everyone in you know
but that's cheating no because he
doesn't like it no but so so what he
addresses
is not the well let me show you he
starts saying the cheating allegations
uh listen cheating in ndas they've been
the rumor Mill's been circulating I know
a lot of you have been asking me
questions
um so I'm gonna try and address this I
guess as uh as tactfully as we can and
Gerald you can just say shut up but
um there have been a lot of story it has
been brought to my attention uh that
there have been some stories out there
circulating
um some old some new regarding uh
divorce that's been going on obviously
I've been going through for a very long
time we have not discussed this and I
want to be very clear this is under
confidentiality from the court from the
judge and uh I will honor that so I
won't be discussing that and I would
caution anyone by the way on either side
move on conclusions on what would
necessarily be incomplete information
because of course so like a recent hit
piece this is something that uh
adultery and I say unrelated to the
divorce because the media smear campaign
is of an accusation so he's going on
saying I've been accused of who's
accused him of uh I mean Candace Owens
good question nobody as far as we were
aware this is so yeah I I went into this
video expecting it to be about the dick
pic stuff and as he was saying this I'm
like
I'm like what the is he even
referring to and I started Googling
around trying to find the hit piece that
he's talking about and nothing was
coming up so it's just like this is just
a guy suddenly unprompted screaming I
didn't cheat on my wife
you think he's doing this to like uh
move away from like I showed my dick to
my co-workers well hold on okay uh we
all know that happened
so no no I know but like people people
would be ripping into him way more if
they were hyper focusing on that and
that's why he's trying to be like I
never cheated with women with women I
mean I women I don't know I think a
lot of his supporters if there's any
left at this point wouldn't be happy to
find out he was a Serial cheater
you know
so what was he referring to the only
post we could find about it was on kiwi
Farms oh geez and we know this is the
post he was talking about right because
it was in the thumbnail
screenshot of the Kiwi Farms Post in the
thumbnail of his video he's addressing
yes I didn't even know this
website still existed by the way it's
like on the dark web now or something or
maybe it's not I don't know but it's
it's not easy nobody knew about this it
is the worst website on the planet so
let me read this post to you hi I'm a
close friend of those in crowded circles
I don't know where else to post this
without getting threats
so here it goes you've all seen the
article about Stephen making his
employees sign crazy uh NDA contracts
you're probably wondering why he already
had articles about him sending dick pics
he's had articles about him flashing
himself so what else could there be I
have the answer he cheated on his on
Hillary not once but three with three
women he said on his show there was no
infidelity but not only is he a
hypocrite but he's a liar below are the
women he fornicated with in an
adulterous adulterous liaison
these are just the ones his employees
know about there's probably more Steve
and then so he links to their all their
Instagram accounts Steven had come into
town to do makeup for the show yeah yeah
okay for the show and Stephen and her
would hook up
she used to uh blank uh she's a big
Second Amendment Pro shooter weapon who
posts her stuff on Instagram Steven
tried to hide her identity from the
staff saying she was his aunt's friend
but they figured it out here's the third
one the Bible is very clear that's what
I see the ladies
uh I I can show it to you I decided we
shouldn't show it because it it's I
don't know we'll see yeah none of them
are public figures these are oh okay
yeah never mind the Bible is very clear
about adultery Exodus 2014 finally dude
and wow
this guy this guy's like writing
notes in here lazy APA formatted and
he's like here's why it's actually
illegal in the Bible okay but these are
his these are his people so that's why I
think this would hit harder than the
dick pic thing because people can just
deny that
Stephen Crowder has always said he's a
Christian but he's a fraud his adultery
Is An Open Secret among the staff but
they can't say anything because he makes
him signed ndas
go back at their social media accounts
you'll see the Francine Crowder Steven's
mom and Dave landu follow them
it's a Nobody But Francine likes her
post I try to Archive some stuff but no
luck but I trust you'll go for it so
okay wait what if it's actually his
aunt's friend or something so it could
just be made up right yeah so here they
provide proof It's like because here's
why hold on like why else can his mom
follow her
is following girls that Stephen Crowder
is piping like on the side that's weird
that is weird I have proof okay this
poster also uh to be clear in that we
didn't get to it but in Steven's video
he admits that he did have relations
with these women wait what that's but
after the divorce he says that there was
no cheating but that he's been dating
since the divorce and he says that they
were all really meaningful but brief
relationships that he had so he did
these girls yeah yeah no he it's not
really in question it's just more the
timeline of when it happened I'm just am
I crazy I'm the one I'm more shocked
that Stephen Crowder is like why is he
addressing this no I'm not girls
I know girls like yeah I did not think
that he was like maybe at all
go to the next image because that's the
proof was actually prompted by somebody
asking that exact question okay so as a
uh good faith signal that they are in
fact close to Crowder's Inner Circle
this person provided a leaked audio
recording of a secret meeting they had
that clearly plays Steven's voice and
his producer's voice now listen to this
this is leaked by this user all aboard
yeah we're the re-platforming kind of
space now look that doesn't mean Nick
Fuentes is going to come on that's
clearly his producer's voice Herald or
whatever Peter Pan the second banana guy
and this clip they're talking about how
they uh distance themselves from Nick
fuentos but if somebody's being silenced
or somebody who's being you know deep
platformed we want to have a
conversation with them if they fit our
battles right we're close enough to our
circle of God right so if somebody is
getting silenced by a YouTuber anywhere
else
it's potentially something we'd like to
talk to uh if if this the channel size
is big enough like it has to make sense
right you can't just be anybody who has
a webcam and wants to put on a show but
yeah somebody's out there yeah I mean
this game seems legit to me right this
is a never before heard record it's like
a secret recording of an internal
meeting at louder with crowd so I mean
like so it's pretty incredible I assume
he's a former employee former employer
or I got it from a foreign employee but
obviously for somebody reason because
this re-platforming thing that they're
talking about that's the Alex Jones
thing that we talked about last week so
this is within the last few weeks and
and I think we're the First Media
Company nobody picked up on this I have
not seen it talked about anywhere and it
I would never have been aware of it if
Crowder hadn't brought it up it's so
awesome brought it up this is a
leftovers exclusive yeah
it's it's it's it's still odd I mean he
says he had sex with them afterwards so
I mean maybe he did maybe he didn't
actually cheat on them because like the
only the only proof that he did actually
cheat on his wife with these uh with
these women is Candace Owens claiming
that uh or insinuating that he actually
committed adultery and also that uh
Stephen CR I mean also this post like
other than that there isn't really
anything that that makes the timeline
stick you know what I mean I'm just
being super critical because like this
website is not oh for sure we should be
skeptical but I I this website is not
exactly all it's proof of is that
they're somewhat credible they if they
have the secret report yeah the guy
might be credible but he could literally
be I mean here think about it this way
if we're if we're looking at every angle
if we're looking at every opportunity
when I see something like this I think
to myself like who's to gain what from
this kind of situation it could be a
fallen uh it could be a former employee
it could be a friend of a former
employee that wants to get back as
Stephen Crowder and then uh make like
use that recording to one create a sense
of authority and credibility only to
turn around and and and uh mix up the
timelines a little bit just like mash
them together
to claim that Stephen Crowder
post-divorce was actually these
ladies uh pre-divorce
it's possible that it's not true yeah
the the only uh the only element of it
that I find rather strange is like that
he did hook up with one of the ladies
that he actually brought into town to do
his makeup uh even if he had sex with
her after the divorce it's still odd
that he was like
you know that's that's a little
suspicious for sure the poster continued
someone said yeah they're not guys I'm
calling uh sorry there's a
little offensive here so I'm not going
to read it just kind of paraphrasing it
most of the guys who have worked for him
all think he's definitely closeted
bisexual but he still makes a show of
being into women that's how it got out
he was banging these chicks
um because he tries to keep it a secret
but ends up bragging to everyone he
works with that actually that makes
total sense because he's like yo I'm not
gay I just had six yeah with this woman
it does like not saying it did happen
but it sounds like something Crowder
would like he would have been I mean
he's the kind of guy that would he
revealed a lot more than uh potentially
uh women on the side he he
literally revealed his penis to his
employees so so another person asked
that's interesting do you have any real
evidence and they responded people of
Affairs don't typically leave hard
evidence lying around the office but I
certainly can offer evidence I have
inside Crowder connections you know the
big re-platforming conference he had
yesterday where he said any Creator
squeezed out by YouTube can join his
platform yeah Crowder specifically
blacklisted Nick Fuentes the hero by the
way the yeah there's the audio of CEO
Gerard Morgan saying so in a private
staff meeting I mean that's pretty
that's yeah no I'm good my husband said
is true though like they could have had
the audio and use that yeah give
themselves more credibility absolutely
like I do I believe that this person uh
most likely is close with someone that
still works there or did work there
until very very very recently absolutely
um but there is no real evidence Beyond
there is no real evidence Beyond Stephen
Crowder
uh bringing one of these ladies while he
was in a marriage according to this
poster till yeah I know but I'm saying
like you can you can actually find hard
evidence for something like that you
know what I mean you can look at
Instagram posts and see if that person
was actually in studio you know what I
mean that that that's more conclusive
than any of the other ones my theory
like their Instagram posts and whatnot
is not exactly inclusive oh she's going
crazy
is getting restless oh my God
no biting crazy dog hey come here
the only uh possible reason
is getting restless why is she she's a
puppy she you can't Coop her up Olivia
said she just pooped so that's why he's
stoked right now
yeah they get pretty stoked don't kill
I'm feeling light feeling free I am the
only possible explanation I can think of
of why he addressed this and the way he
did is that he knows there's an article
coming that's going to completely out
this story and he's trying to get ahead
maybe yeah I can see that yeah but
here's his thumbnail where he shows the
Kiwi Farms screen that's insane what a
stupid thing to do by the way
because like we wouldn't have heard
about this never would have heard about
this most people would not have heard
about this if he didn't
that's why I I can only assume that he
knows the reporter is working on this
yeah that does seem yeah otherwise I
mean where's the original article
where's the
dogs in the do you put in the thumbnail
from like I did find that one eventually
but only from only from seeing it in his
thumbnail is that like a Daily Dot
article or is it no no it's the the
current here it is it's current revolt
and it's what the is there I got it
right it's like nothing and the post had
like no engagement um let's not put it
on screen because they have the QE Farms
Post in their uh not censored so anyway
this post has 11 likes I mean right and
I I had to dig to even find this this is
just like a Blog that literally nobody
uh visits about him cheating and this
kiwi Farmer's post I mean how odd is
this yeah and I searched around on
Twitter to see if there was like buzz in
his circle after the episode because I
thought surely his audience must be like
me and thinking what is he referring to
with this and uh and I couldn't like
there's like no discourse about this at
all also Even's the only person talking
about it well well I'm assuming other
people are going to be curious about it
now
one other juicy little morsel a Sam
Cedar friend of the show made a
prediction that the mysterious leaker is
actually his producer Gerard Morgan
and a juicy morsel of a uh tip came out
that suggests he might be a riot now
check this out
um
here is uh he deleted the Twitter post
but yeah so here's the images here this
is the the author of the hit of the
quote hit piece on crowder the original
one the actual Diana the the dick pic
article Gerard is in her comments bro
back in 2019 happy birthday
this is the girl that he might have
cheated with no no this is the author of
the of the quote hit piece about the
dick pics and stuff at current Revolt or
no this is totally separate this is
about the media oh this is Media Matters
this is the Media Matters author yeah
it's not I think it was media it was me
no yeah I don't know it was mediaite
yeah it wasn't Media Matters so she's
the one that wrote this article and she
has this anonymous source nobody knows
who it is Sam was like it's got to be
his producer here he is in her in her
responses 2019. that's crazy he went
back and erased it but wait there's more
um
and then more currently here we're
basically outing
the we're helping Stephen Crowder right
now these are the routing potentially
the rat yeah
well he better make an example of him
you know what I mean I'd like to see
that
and maybe even in Crowder Style with a
leather Whip and uh a gag ball love to
see that uh here he he liked this post
okay outed he's the CEO he's not just
like right user he's like
the guy and then even furthermore
there's even another damning uh clue
here going back to
uh 2023 this is this is breaking bro
this is in January of this year she
posted a article about uh a tribute to
her father and Gerard Gerald is in the
comments this is really touching this
man is a fan of her work and once this
post went up on Sam's subreddit her all
of his comments were erased this man is
her anonymous source potentially
allegedly maybe allegedly and
theoretically
what do you think it's all dude his his
world is collapsing I mean just ruined I
mean the clip the audio clip that was
leaked in the previous uh Forum that we
were looking at actually did paint
Gerald in a decent light because he was
the one who was
outspoken against Nick Fuentes
so it doesn't even look good that he was
against Nick
yeah I think like excwiper freaks are
gonna well yes but also
if that were to be if that were to be
played in the media yes he would look
better he would look much better he's
looking for another job yeah he would
look like the the guy who's like the
reasonable Republican in the crew that
is uh saying no to that right
yeah love it all I mean yeah he's he's
uh
he's definitely got a lot of problems
um chicken's coming home the roost I
guess I want to check back in on Trump's
fourth indictment real fast but can we
check in on Mike Lindell
um I'm gonna guess that he is still
ranting I want to see where he's at
anybody willing to take that bet in this
historical
what do you know let's see this is live
how many people are watching now for
about five years now when we talk about
that that's where you we we've been
refreshed three months I did yeah yeah
no that should be uh but let's listen in
let's listen to be accurate working on
this election crime Barrel site which
you're going to hear about in a little
bit okay there's other tools you've got
to hear about today
um and that is one of them so anyone out
there looking for right now like I say
to get enough donations where I can make
them all
we've got enough that we're producing to
to get these false election we have to
get the the big ones covered this fall
I'll tell you that
I got 60 Millions another five three
weeks to go in and just completely wiped
out on money right and uh but like I
said yeah that's what I mean
he is right about that I don't think
he's like I think he's a real believer
every time I can I think Mike Lindell is
a True Believer oh yeah
because like no one is no one is wiping
out their uh their entire net worth
like this
he's putting he's putting it on the line
I do respect him for that look is he
breaking down because he's losing all
his money guys uh Mike hold on to that
thought protect your retirement from CD
politics DC politics get a free info kit
on gold IRAs by texting
rsbn 2989898
um
um we're gonna come back to the the plan
and stuff again but I wanna the uh I
want to bring up the important part the
one of the big pieces to this is that we
have people reporting the things or the
people
we know if there was if there were
people I can see that the convention
he's hosting is in full swing
and hearts and Minds my friends hearts
and Minds
uh Trump was indicted for the fourth
time I mean woohoo I guess I don't know
what the it's like bring it on this
is the Georgia one where he tried to I
did everything right and they indicted
me he was looking for the votes he
couldn't find the votes but now he's
busted God 91 uh he's now facing 91
charges across four separate indictments
it's all happening for uh president
Donald Trump
uh and then this time actually he is
going to be perp walked and get his mug
shot taken the uh Georgia yeah
uh this D.A or the Attorney General uh
said
he's being charged on Ricoh charges
which to me makes so much sense he I
mean it is racketeering he's a mob boss
bring out the Ricoh charges
and uh the beautiful irony of course is
that Rudy Giuliani who uh was a
Trailblazer and using Ricoh charges in
New York when he was governor to take
down the mob is now being charged with
Rico
charges himself yeah he is Mr Rico
Suave
so Suave
um
yeah so he's going down poor Rudy he
doesn't have money to pay for his
lawyers poor guy hasn't he been
through enough giuliani's struggling
under massive legal bills after
defending Trump
God damn just give the man a break dude
he's doing his best
uh yeah 13 uh counts of racketeering
he's got 20 feet he's looking real
livable that's what I'm thinking yeah
yeah that's what I think for sure I
think he's like a very self-interested
guy I don't think he's a good Trump Die
Hard
and I think
he is at least smart enough to know
that he can cover his own ass
um a lot of these guys don't think they
they probably if they were to defend
Donald Trump they'd probably do it
because they don't think like any kind
of legal repercussions is going to
happen to Trump
um Tim Paul has been banging the war
drums claiming Civil War over and over
again okay go get a rifle I mean
don't all right well I'm just saying a
video go grab the rifle let's
let's go see what you got well the
the reality is you know what I mean
where's the Civil War Tim we have seen
uh that in the Post January 6th world
especially when a lot of these entitled
business owners that attended January 6
and participated in it
finally got legal repercussions that
they were not expecting at all there has
been a genuine momentum shift
in uh on the ground
acts of protest from the Trump side
that's why when you go to the
courthouses every single indictment you
expect there to be like at least
somewhat of a crowd and every single
indictment the crowd is smaller and
smaller
so I find that really interesting
um I don't think that it's happening I
don't think that there is any kind of
real momentum
this comment is fantastic uh the top
come under comment under Civil War claim
the only civil war you'll fight is in
the one in your mind when faced with the
choice between what to grab a Mountain
Dew Code Red or Monster energy from the
little fridge in your basement
not bad I feel like that's an attack on
me I caught a stray there for no reason
that's a very difficult Choice sometimes
well to beat bring it Bali
well to be fair you're not calling for a
civil war I'm not so the Civil War in my
mind between whichever Mountain Dew
energy drink I want it's a tough choice
I don't yeah but grab the little sword
and and musk it off your wall and go you
know what I mean these Slims go for it
I'm not gonna lie they have they have
turned to selectivism quite quite a bit
over the course of the past couple of
years like they did go from attending
Trump rallies and actually being a
physical presence everywhere
uh the Trump supporters I mean to
straight up just like crying on Twitter
right yep
um which is good I guess that's progress
in some ways but I do not foresee this
uh turning into a legitimate
uh I don't know a legitimate Riot
anytime soon no because there's like 45
divorced dads that are jobless enough to
attend these sorts of things and they're
all out of their minds like
they're not getting the same
they're not getting the same uh energy
in the crowd there's not enough people
that are out there putting their bodies
on the line for Donald Trump
uh yeah I mean real sad it's a fantasy
he's living in
Ben Shapiro had an interesting take he
said whatever you think of trump
indictment one thing is for certain the
glass has now been broken over and over
again political opponents can now be
targeted by legal enemies running for
office now carries the legal risk of
going to jail on all sides that isn't I
mean right and what's interesting though
is that he wrote a book about it he
wrote a book exactly called uh
it's you know you can even still get it
on Amazon the people versus Barack Obama
the criminal case against the Obama
Administration in which he details out
actually utilizing Rico's as a as a
mechanism to
to to uh potentially prosecute former
presidents and right and he actually
even says it I mean here and you don't
need to I mean that's what's so insane
in this country you don't need to
this is what the right the racketeer
influenced in corrupt organizations act
the RICO Act was created in 1970 to go
after the Mafia the premise of that act
was that it was very difficult to tie
the heads of the Mafia the Don Corleone
figures from the to the Luca Brazzi
figures because there was never a direct
Chain of Command right there was never a
direct order so they created Rico to say
okay it's obvious that you wanted this
person to be killed you're obviously a
conspiracy and so now we're going to
drag you all into court together that's
what the executive branch is it is a
mafioso organization
you don't understand that was Obama
pretty pretty great who is uh Muslim
listen a criminal Muslim Rudy I want you
to go outside the dildo shop
give a message to the people
I wanted 11
000.
870 bucks
you're dripping for Christ's sake Brody
have to look well afterwards going to
the dildo shop pick yourself up
something nice
[Music]
so Ben uh you know Ben Ben is uh
chirping about it now and he's saying
it's actually not hypocritical uh and I
didn't change my mind about this because
it's like it's just the Democrats are
abusing it for silly reasons or whatever
the and it's like his original
taken 2014 when he was on Larry King
show was actually quite apt in my
opinion
uh where he said maybe these uh
presidents will think twice about
behaving in criminal ways you could
prosecute every former uh Administration
but that was of course he was saying
that because he wanted to come across as
impartial when absolutely advocating to
do this to Barack Obama now that it's
happening to Donald Trump he is singing
different tune
of course yeah
here is the Gorka this is the best one
this is the best Line This is the best
line of defense I've ever heard in my
entire life this is basically the end of
the conversation yeah he's gonna end
this right now Brooke is kind of
the inverse the sun yeah his head is so
giant
I love that it means he's really smart
right yeah or it means he has a birth
defect I don't know yeah we're not
really he's got that good vitesi Ren
skull and there's nothing wrong with
birth defects we love our birth defect
folks yeah
there's some
some of them
they hit it did I hit it
fine it's fine we love them
I mean that's kind of true right I I've
got mad birth defects bro yeah my birth
defect microcephalies no laughing matter
Ethan what's your birth defect other
than the shoulder it grows sexually well
I mean I don't know I I have uh I'm
double jointed there it is freak
let's hear what you got to say and let's
be clear I mean read the transcript of
the Rapids Burger call I've got it in
front of me president Trump said what he
said I just want to find 11 780 votes
that's like saying I just want to have
vanilla ice cream for dessert it's not a
crime to say I just want something
they're trying to turn that into a crime
it's as you'll get to sad this is the
president said it's in Iowa the weekend
this is about election interference and
preventing him from being the man who
will unseat Joe Biden here I'll use it
I'll use it different I'll I'll change
the words a little bit I just want you
to put 11 780
dollars into this burlapse
[Music]
just just stop just stop going okay it
says too don't explain the joke please I
had to hit the butt yeah
I just want something and then something
terrible that's the joke and I didn't
explain it right but what's the
difference right it's like Al Qaeda is
saying okay yeah it's I just want yeah
to crash airplanes into the Twin Towers
yeah it's not
I love
the conservative
strategy of just like
trying to basically claim that no crime
could ever occur
by just speech like you could never
engage in an act of conspiracy you can
never engage in fraud you can't do
anything
by just speaking like the idea like
Charles Manson completely innocent never
touched a a person literally but why is
why is Charles Manson in prison why was
he why was he sent to prison after all
it was just simply asking for ice cream
but it's funny because this whole
thing's about Ricoh charges where Ben
Shapiro's like yeah no I get the need
and then the gorka's like every mob boss
should be acquitted for all they want is
saying they want stuff yeah
because once again men can't have
hobbies you can't you can't ask to to
find 11 780 votes very specific number
reasonably transcript please
all I said is I want my wife dead yeah
does it mean that she died under
mysterious circumstances I had nothing
to do with it there's the other great
line what man doesn't want his wife dead
their other great line of defense is
like when it's it's unsuccessful it
didn't work yeah we tried legal methods
and they said no so we went the illegal
route is that illegal
and so this is the end of the
conversation though they basically took
it all the way to like yeah we did that
you
you know what I mean yeah so what
I mean even I watched I watched Ben
Shapiro's uh video uh God forsaken uh it
was only like nine minutes uh directly
addressing the hypocrisy of him having
written this book and everything and it
was notable to me it was 100 just well
why don't they do this to Hunter Biden
and the Biden cram crime family he'd at
no point
said that Trump shouldn't be indicted
under Rico charges which I thought was
interesting dude I don't care dude if
they want to do the hunter Biden thing I
really don't care let them do it take
them down yeah yeah I agree yeah hey put
them they praise him it is Shady
what he did why is it why is he getting
paid half a million dollars from from
Ukraine energy well they don't care
about the the thing is like first of all
I don't think they give a about
like Hunter Biden
utilizing the Biden last name to get
money from foreign Nationals right like
they want to tie it to Joe Biden yes
yeah which is ironic because you
definitely could tie Jared Kushner and
Donald Trump Jr to Trump in way more
direct ways uh then these guys are
trying to tie hunterbot into Joe Biden
um but ultimately at the end of the day
if if there is uh something that is
illegal yeah you should go to jail I'm
cool man but you don't want to they want
to tie it to Joe Biden let's go do that
too I don't care it's like well that
would be heck there's nothing to do with
the other yeah I would also be sick but
I don't think they have enough juice
there so they're just like trying to
create momentum around it in these like
very weird ways where like for example
Republicans love making a show of things
right
but the Congressional hearings that have
taken place with the hunter Biden
investigation task force yeah have
always been behind closed doors where
they're like interviewing Witnesses and
whatnot if they actually had
legitimate proof connecting Hunter Biden
to Joe Biden through the witnesses that
they've uh that they've cross-examined
they would be blasting that on every
media outlet they would have Open Door
sessions they would invite cameras uh
they would cross-examine in public right
and then everyone in America would see
the reality of the the Biden crime
family but the reason why they're doing
it in closed door sessions is so they
can like kind of massage the truth and
cultivate a narrative uh which they
effectively do on Fox News if you watch
any Fox News you'll hear this all the
time they can't shut the up about
it but then the news articles that come
out of the closed door sessions or even
the the real quotes that the Republicans
that are in those closed door sessions
give to the media is always like well
it's not exactly there's not anything
really tying them together
you know well and like I said they have
this whole like mythology that Democrats
or other or liberals or leftist care and
our care about Hunter Biden being
innocent I care about Hunter Biden well
yeah I mean listen he's got a nice
is I haven't seen his call to be honest
people are saying he's got a nice penis
people are saying he has a nice penis he
he likes to do crack which is the the
working class uh cocaine you know many
other people he's a man of the people he
wants strippers to unionize right you
know or sex work it's kind of funny
because
everything that they've gotten Hunter
Biden on I've said this before
Biden on is basically like the
Republican Bingo
um they got him on gun charges uh
unlawful position of a gun because you
lied and said you aren't Under the
Influence when purchasing it okay which
is incredibly Republican that's a Second
Amendment violation brother you know
what I mean yep uh tax evasion again
oh yeah oh God just means he's smart we
hate paying taxes that means I'm smart
right
um and they they were like oh he's
failing to pay child support that's like
that's the Republican Trifecta wait is
he really not paying child support no I
think he is but they were I remember
hearing about like uh
them claiming that he was hiding his
like love child uh from one of his
Affairs so yeah I mean listen Eat Your
Heart Out Hunter Biden I don't care it's
got one's got nothing to do with the
other you know what I mean dude let's do
it all let's have a let's have a
ball
um
I know that we're out of time but I have
just been informed of some uplifting
news
uh to kind of Bring Me Up full circle no
not Mike Lindell related bird related
the birds are safe people whoa the birds
are safe let's go you Ethan that's
incredible the bird they were right
there man and they they lit God damn I
mean well they can fly
well not if they're trapped in one of
those cages oh my God stop well they're
alive we're good we're good all right
before so so that's that's uplift that's
Fantastic Four burbs and then can we
just check in with Mike one last time
before we leave you love him so much
well you know this is breaking this is
historical uh okay one second uh uh oh
uh-oh hopefully the deep sea didn't get
him deep stage
he's not gonna be dumb for another I'm
not exaggerating like 12 to 14 more
hours of this let's hear it let's see
it's not even exaggerating you can you
can play it again I tried to think what
they do
well this may be why they go silent
because now we're going to go into
management organ Management Consultant
org charts right so this is exciting
this is my organization here now that
was set up the election crime Barrel so
you see at the top then and Patrick will
go through it now
we have a real-time crime reports and
everything comes when we have those
groups out in the field that need help
like defend Florida every single this is
the Hub now that runs the engine where
all right well thanks for watching
everybody here playing all these
divisions was that you can keep yourself
into the distance
the beginning
pop-up shop on Sunday at reconstruction
on Melrose on Melrose you know the
street yeah reconstruct is the
reconstruct Studios is a oh public place
okay so the shop reconstruct yeah I'll
be doing a meet and greet and a pop-up
I'll be there we're gonna be giving away
uh pieces
that are cut and so reconstruct X
ideology John Brown Edition
collaboration fun cut and sew pieces
handmade uh very unique hopefully you
guys appreciate and enjoy that as long
as you spend or have spent since July
1st 250 on the website also there's the
ideology uh hoodie a new ideology hoodie
that came out as well there it is folks
it's all happening
please bring Mike back yeah all the way
literally being outside so guys we'll
see you tomorrow
well we're scrambling pennies together
again thank you for being here
yet again all these Grassroots groups
that are out here all right guys see you
tomorrow
when they're going off
seven thousand dollars to get a list of
Voters I mean I don't know about how
many of you guys have that sitting
around in your wallet but I don't so
that's that so this is really when
you're talking about how much it cost me
to put on this event one million dollars
and I borrowed it you know that's how
important this is I'm serious you guys
this is a bit this is for all the
marbles folks this is that this is it
and so we need your help supporting this
and then the continued operations
obviously and uh
um one of the reasons I had struggled in
politics was I didn't know how to ask
for money so before
and so then the last is the operations
unit so that's the back office that's
stuff every organization deals with
right and before before